saudi arabia
birthplace of the prophet muhammad the
prophet muhammad
our graphics department must have
decided against that one for some reason
now
saudi arabia has been in the news this
week for a truly appalling reason
and it has to do with saudi journalist
jamal khashoggi a u.s resident and
columnist for the washington post who
has not been seen since he stepped to
the saudi consulate in turkey to pick up
some paperwork
12 days ago this is captured on closed
circuit cameras stepping into what
turkish authorities believe
was a death trap turkish authorities
have identified 15 saudi men as persons
of interest
only hours before khashoggi went missing
several of them were caught on camera
arriving in istanbul a turkish official
tells the new york times saudi agents
had dismembered his body with a bone saw
they brought for the purpose
it's absolutely horrific and the saudis
deny it happened although
let us all agree on this a bone saw in
any context
is an immediate red flag thanks so much
for inviting me over for thanksgiving
craig the turkey's delicious
the stuffing is perfect that's a very
large bum sauce and i just remembered i
have to leave now
now saudi officials have scrambled to
explain all the suspicious activities
surrounding his disappearance with the
saudi-owned channel al-arabiya
claiming that the 15 people who turned
up in istanbul
were just tourists which is clearly
given that flight logs showed that most
of the men arrived on a private charter
plane at 3 13
am and that all of them departed the
same day they arrived which is a pretty
weird
vacation isn't it i want to see istanbul
but only for a few hours
mostly at night and i need to bring my
bonesaw
also the whole we were just tourist
excuse isn't even a new one
in the wake of russia's poisoning of
sergey sripal the russian suspects tried
the same thing
what were you doing there our friends
had been suggesting for a long time that
we visit this wonderful town
salisbury a wonderful town
yes
there's the famous salisbury cathedral
famous not only in europe but in the
whole world
it's famous for its 123 meter spire
it's famous for its clock the one of the
first ever created in the world that's
still working
okay so first i love how the reporter
immediately became suspicious when they
called salisbury
a wonderful town she knows what's up
it's like if you heard someone call
celery a delicious treat
look i don't know what else you're not
telling the truth about but now i
definitely know you're a liar
and second it's famous for its 123 meter
spire
they sound like they're reading directly
off the wikipedia page for salisbury
oh why do i love salisbury it's simple
the population is 40
302 and their member of parliament is
john glenn a conservative
whose eight year tenure has been widely
viewed as a failure
open brackets citation needed close
brackets
but look look for all the saudis in
denials
things are not looking good right now as
the turkish government reportedly have
audio and video proof
of the assassination look this story is
incredibly grim
because while this may be the first that
you have heard of jamal khashoggi
he's long been a significant figure in
saudi arabia a thoughtful
and by no means radical critic of the
saudi royal family and this is all
worrying
because the only reason to kill a
journalist in your own consulate
with 15 people and a bone saw you flew
in that day it's because you wanted to
send a message
and you were sure you could get away
with it which raises the question
why would they be so sure of that and
part of that answer may have to do with
us so tonight let's take a look at
america's relationship with saudi arabia
because we have a long and morally
compromised history in short in very
short for decades
we have had a relationship based on
strategic interests not
shared values they have oil we need it
they opposed iran
and so did we and for those and other
reasons u.s presidents have to varying
degrees
been willing to pander to saudi arabia
and in doing so we've conveniently
turned a blind eye to a lot of things
from human rights abuses to the saudi
leadership's role in funding religious
extremism
even while partnering with us to fight
it it's always been
a very complicated relationship but in
the last couple of years it's actually
gotten significantly closer
thanks to two new leaders trump and
crown prince mohammed bin salman
and let's take the prince first though
his father the king
is still alive since last year the
prince has effectively been running the
country and has branded himself as
mbs the young new face of saudi arabia
he made the cover of time magazine under
the headline charm offensive
and 60 minutes profiled him as a
progressive voice for the country
his reforms inside saudi arabia have
been revolutionary
he is emancipating women introducing
music in cinema
and cracking down on corruption now
there is some truth to that
he's attempted to reduce the influence
of some hardline clerics uh he has
agreed to let women drive
and he's allowed movie theaters after a
35-year ban although i will note that
one of the very first movies they showed
there was
and this is true the emoji movie which
in hindsight is actually how it was
always supposed to be seen by a group of
people who had never seen a good movie
to compare it to
now now all of that has been combined
with a major plan to reorient
the saudi economy away from oil and
toward technology called vision 2030.
to that end mbs has gone on a world tour
this year to reassure investors that
saudi arabia is stable
and progressive and that businesses
should feel comfortable working with
them he's taken meetings with tim cook
bill gates and richard branson and has
even had starbucks with michael
bloomberg
incidentally while the starbucks
baristas miraculously nailed mohammed
bin salman
bloomberg still ended up with a cup
reading mikey boomberg
now as part of
his pr push mbs started an annual
business conference called
the future investment initiative or as
it's known davos in the desert
the first one was held just last year at
the ritz carlton in riyadh featuring
leaders
of many big name companies as well as
the usual futuristic tech like
this
we have smart investors here and they
are very selective
about what they invest in well
i think i'm special i can use my
expressive face to communicate with
people
but why is it important for you to have
an expressive most of the time i feel
positive
god oh god that is a creepy smile
that's the exact same smile that i've
seen the queen give when she has to
interact with a commoner
oh i believe you won some kind of
contest to come to my house and look at
my things
what a positive day for one of us
don't touch anything
but mbs's pr push isn't just toward
attracting businesses it's also toward
changing the world's perception of saudi
arabia to that end he struck a 10-year
deal
with one of the most popular and most
american franchises there is
world wrestling entertainment or wwe
they held their first of many events
there
back in april and audiences around the
world were treated to water war
propaganda
about the new saudi arabia including a
video showing women happily driving
men dancing and tourist destination
beauty shots as well as
constant excited compliments throughout
the broadcast for the first time
wwe bringing an event of this magnitude
to saudi arabia this vibrant progressive
city
our host tonight it's all part of course
of the saudi vision
2030 king abdullah city stadium just got
on its feet that area has been reserved
for the
saudi royal family the house of assad i
want to send a genuine thank you
to the kingdom of saudi arabia wow
it seems the wwe is overtly pro-saudi
arabia
as it is blatantly homoerotic which is
to say
intensely
but the truth is mbs is far from the
political reformer that he's been
presented as in fact
scratch any positive story about him and
you will find a much grimmer truth
underneath
for instance while the country did get
headlines for ending its ban on women
driving
just weeks before authorities arrested
about a dozen female activists
who'd campaigned for the right to drive
even that investment conference had a
dark code because just one week later
at the exact same hotel this happened
new footage from inside the ritz-carlton
hotel
in saudi arabia's capital riyadh shows a
dramatic transformation
from a favorite haunt of the well-heeled
into arguably the world's most luxurious
prison
it's true mbs used that ritz carlton to
lock up hundreds of businessmen and
members of the royal family in a
so-called anti-corruption campaign
at least 17 detainees were reportedly
hospitalized for physical abuse
and one saudi military officer died in
custody which is obviously insane and
horrifying
because the only hotel where you expect
to be murdered is a days inn
hence their slogan days in expect to be
murdered here
meanwhile bin salman has been aggressive
with his neighbours launching a blockade
of qatar last year that continues to
this day
as does an absolutely brutal war in
yemen that has resulted in over 16 000
casualties
and killed over 1200 children the saudi
campaign of air strikes has been
catastrophic as this man attested while
standing in front of what used to be is
hung
saudi arabia bombs without care how many
of your family were killed
27 lives 27 people
from one family can you think of any
reason why
your family and this house might have
been struck i am not a leader or
anything i work as a barber
i that's clearly terrible and for the
record at the very least
there is no justification for violence
against a barber
and that is coming from me if anyone
has a justification for a blood grudge
against barbers
it would be yours truly because of what
they did to me
and yet and yet
as all of this has happened our current
president has continued to bend over
backwards to accommodate
and ignore bin salman's worst excesses
and sometimes
even celebrate them after that clampdown
on corruption at the ritz carlton
many around the world sounded the alarm
but trump went the other way
trump endorsed crown prince mohammed bin
salman's new corruption crackdown
tweeting quote
i have great confidence in king salman
and the crown prince of saudi arabia
they know exactly what they are doing
right
but just because they know what they're
doing doesn't mean that what they're
doing
is good michael jordan knew exactly what
he was doing when he wore this mustache
in a haines commercial
he was seeing how far this whole michael
jordan thing could take him and the
answer was apparently
through hitler and beyond
and that that actually fits with the
larger pattern of donald trump and saudi
arabia because since taking office he
has catered
cater to them at every single turn he
made saudi arabia the first foreign
country he visited
as president and he seemed to have an
absolutely great time there dancing with
a sword
and famously groping a weird glowing orb
after which i assume michael cohen
instinctively offered the orb 130 000
and told it to keep quiet and look it
really shouldn't be that surprising to
anybody
that trump has so enthusiastically
embraced the saudi royal family they
have the two qualities he admires most
in the world
having a lot of money and giving it to
him he basically said as much on the
campaign trail
saudi arabia and i get along great with
all of them they buy apartments from me
they spend 40 million 50 million am i
supposed to dislike them i like them
very much
yeah of course buying an apartment from
trump is a sure-fire way to get him to
like you along with
wearing one of his hats being under 25
years old with a size 32 double d
and not being eric he's a he's a simple
man
with simple tastes and trump's
businessman view of the saudis is just
people with money don't ask too many
questions
has carried over now that he's president
when bin salman came to the white house
trump called a press conference in the
oval office where he boasted
about the amount of arms that they were
buying from us essentially using mbs as
a human easel some of the things that
have been approved and are currently
under construction and will be delivered
to saudi arabia very soon and that's for
their protection but if you look
in terms of dollars three billion
dollars
533 million dollars
525 million dollars
that's peanuts for you you've increased
it 880 million dollars
645 million dollars six billion dollars
that's
uh for frigates
first first has any human in the history
of the world more obviously just learned
a word than he just learned the word
frigates
frigates but second look at bin salman's
face there as it hits him
just how much trump likes money it's
like the face of a babysitter who
realized you can pacify a screaming kid
with twizzlers oh i thought this was
going to be difficult
but if all you want is twizzlers i've
got loads of them here take all you want
and shut the up
and look look i am by no means saying
that trump is the first u.s president to
make distasteful arms deals with the
saudis
we've been doing it for decades the
obama administration
still sold them weapons even as saudi
arabia got involved in yemen but trump
has continued doing so even a signed
amount of saudi recklessness in
airstrikes two months ago they dropped
an american-made bomb
on a school bus full of children but
just a month later
trump's defense secretary said that
saudi arabia was doing everything it
could
to prevent civilian casualties and we
carried on supporting them my point here
is
at every turn trump has gone out of his
way to accommodate the saudis
he doesn't even have an ambassador to
the kingdom our relationship with them
is being handled personally
by jared ivanka trump's real doll
and and the saudis seem understandably
very happy with that situation
kushner took an unannounced trip to
saudi arabia in 2017 to meet with the
young prince
months later mbs reportedly boasted that
kushner was quote
in his pocket which bin salman denied
yeah
of course he's in their pocket he's
jared
that face was born to be maneuvered into
someone's pocket his secret service
nickname is probably wallet keys and a
little bit of lint
so so while the fact that the us has
enabled saudi arabia
is nothing new the extent to which trump
is prioritizing money above all else is
really dangerous
is it any wonder that they have been
emboldened here after mbs's roundup of
his rivals
trump tweeted his support after his
blockade of qatar trump for some reason
took credit for it and that kind of
has consequences
time and again trump has chosen extreme
friendliness with
mbs a leader who in the words of one
saudi critic has created
a climate of fear and intimidation going
on to say
we saudis deserve better that critic
was jamal khashoggi the journalist who
is widely thought to have been murdered
in the saudi consulate
and while trump has said that saudi
arabia faces severe punishment
if it's proven they were behind this
does anyone really believe
that that is something that he's
honestly committed to a much more
revealing response came in the oval
office
after the news of khashoggi's
disappearance broke just watch him
render in real time the cost-benefit
analysis that he was applying to the
situation
again this took place in turkey and to
the best of our knowledge
khashoggi is not a united states citizen
is that right or
is that right he's a permanent resident
okay we don't like it
john we don't like it and we don't like
it even a little bit
but as to whether or not we should stop
110 billion dollars from being spent in
this country
knowing they have four or five
alternatives two very good alternatives
that would not be acceptable to me he is
openly demonstrating to the entire world
and to saudi arabia specifically
that arms deal much more important than
butchered journalists
look clearly giving saudi arabia green
lights for two solid years has had
consequences and a lot of people now
have some big decisions to make
the second annual davos in the desert
begins nine days from now and already
all of these companies have pulled out
although as of right now
treasury secretary steve mnuchin is
still planning to attend which is
ridiculous
the desert is comfortably hot enough
without that smoke show am i right
am i right smoke show right
he can get it that's a me face
am i right am i right on that now
now as for the wwe
while they say they are monitoring the
situation their gigantic crown jewel
event is still scheduled for november
meaning john cena
could well be back there doing this
which i guess in this context would mean
you don't see these human rights abuses
right here
as for the president again look every
u.s leader has chosen to make
compromises when it comes to saudi
arabia but trump
may well be the first one who doesn't
see it as a compromise
because he and mbs are similar in some
of the worst possible ways
they both love money they're both a
product of inherited wealth
they both love self-promotion yet
disdain the press and they even both
share a design aesthetic that amounts to
elvis tries to remember what versailles
looks like but can't
and trump's intense bromance with mbs is
bad news because when you set
no boundaries on an oppressive regime
they are always going to ask themselves
how much can we get away with here and
as we saw this week
the answer to that may well be pretty
much
anything